here we have her mind structured gel I
had to get away from circuitry I needed
something that could arrange and
rearrange on a molecular level to keep
its form when required a common theme in
science fiction is the creation of
artificial intelligence often this means
the creation of an artificial brain some
electrical circuit that mimics the
action of the human brain now I've
always been curious about this so when I
had the opportunity to go to University
College London and meet with dr. Ali
Jennings who's just done his PhD in
neurophysiology I wanted to ask him a
simple question can we build a freight
brain can we build an artificial
intelligence oh god I want to say yes
first I want to explain why we should be
able to brain cells run on electricity
right your brain brain waves as I like
to call weights in fact you can read the
electricity off someone's head with an
EEG if your brain cells can work by
electricity then and we can build
electrical circuits it sort of logically
leads on that we should be able to build
ourselves an electrical brain let's
think about an electrical circuit
no let's take a simple one maybe the
simplest one that you could do so we'll
have a cell and in this case just like a
no electrical cell and then some wires
and then a resistor and across that
resistor
that's a voltmeter well done GCSE
physics parent passes from this end the
negative end of a battery goes round
hits the resistor something goes through
and gets the positive side depending on
how strong the resistor is and your
voltmeter
tells you exactly how much current
difference there is across the two sides
of the resistor that is a very very very
very simple model of a cell a neuron
doesn't look like this and you're on
looks something like this
these are our dendrites and this is our
axon and that you may have noticed
doesn't really look that doesn't really
look anything like that but what is
crucial about it is that this battery is
pumping negative charge in the form of
electrons that way and this cell spends
actually a really huge amount of its
biological energy pumping negative
charge this way into the cell now the
current wants to flow back out but this
the cell membrane is made of fat lipids
so fat won't conduct electricity very
easily in our simple cell diagram cell
membrane is the resistor and the cell
has lots of mechanisms that inform the
battery every time because you can set
this up so you set up this this little
tiny circuit across the membrane in the
cell you can actually use changes in
that membrane so you can if you can you
can measure how much charge is on either
side how negative the inside is go to
the outside and you can use that to
transmit signals because if the membrane
changes the membrane voltage changes in
a certain way that will have transmitted
a certain signal across the cell and
because charge travels through the cell
you can send that signal very long
distances which is the basis of
electrical conductance in the brain and
that sounds a little bit like what
sounds a lot like the electrical
conductance of a circuit now you may ask
how in God's name do you claim to know
this actually I can show you if you want
to come with me
so how do you record electrical signals
from individual cells that's something
that seniors doing right now that's
right so we are looking at a single
neuron which I've put my electrode into
and we're now able to see all the
electrical activity that's happening to
that cell right now we've got an
electrical circuit and in my pipette
which is the big bit of glass that's
sticking into that cell so there is a
bit of wire in there that's my main
electrode and we've got on the other
side of the cell just floating around in
the bath we've got a ground electrode so
we're able to measure the potential
difference between the electrode and the
ground so if one is more positive than
other we can see that if one is more
negative than the other we can see that
so it's a bit like if you're trying to
measure across a battery a 9-volt
battery you'd have a nine volt
difference so we're looking at
millivolts not lots so it's much smaller
but it's basically the same principle so
in the trace there's always kind of like
tiny little bumps going on and that's it
and when you get those massive spikes
what is that right so those are action
potentials so what's happening here is
that you've got enough glutamatergic
transmission that the cell is hitting at
section between a threshold and that
means it takes off at it starts are
taking take control of its own voltage
and it fires off this a big positive
current and that's gonna be enough to
make it release chemical transmission to
its neighbors every time you see one of
these deflections in the current every
time you see a change in the voltage of
the cell membrane what that is is the
synaptic circuitry like connecting so
it's the point where one cell has made
an electrical link to the next one not a
direct electrical link but by releasing
neurotransmitter it has triggered an
another electrical impulse in a
neighboring cell so it's the beginnings
of a circuit
two parts of a circle together and if
you see the kind of the branches between
them the connections that they're making
between them between the individual
cells that million millions probably yep
millions of synaptic connections right
so if you think about that that's each
cell connected to ten hundred other
cells maybe more yep yep easily 100 it
could be a thousand that next cell will
be connects to another cell and it's
nice out ha ha ha and they may
eventually connect back for the same
year yeah
so that is the circuit that's it there's
an electrical circuit mm-hmm but it's
not just one it's thousands some of
which contain neurons which are involved
in other electrical circuits so that in
miniature and in a very unorganized way
who is how your brain is structures so
in order to build an artificial brain
you'd need to build an electrical
circuit that's incredibly complex but
this actually isn't even the major
problem you know there's a few billion
cells in the brain so that's not beyond
the size of circuits that we can build
you know we can build something that big
but what it is about is actually more
fundamental kind of difference between
the electricity that you find in a
circuit and the way that brain cells
move charge around so the flow of charge
it's electricity the brain cells do it
in a very very different way in a
circuit this is made of metal and the
free movement of electrons around this
metal band this metal ring is the
current that's the movement of charge in
a biological circuit there's no metal so
you can't get the same electron flow it
just won't work there isn't anything to
conduct those electrons so what biology
does is the electrons are carried on
ions and ions are charged atoms so a
negative ion has one extra electron a
positive ion has
one less electron so the movement of
negative ions is the same thing as the
movement of electrons through metal
because the electrons are still moving
they just have to be mean carried by an
ion the really crucial bit is and the
reason why I was so kind of hesitant
about answering their artificial brain
question is that there's not just one
kind of ion ion come ions come in as
many there's many kind of miles of there
are elements so our brain only uses
three or four the big ones are sodium
potassium chloride those three different
ions are basically like three different
flavors of current you could transfer
your current like four I do you for
transfer it by sodium or you could
transfer it by potassium so that gives
you three different ways of controlling
your current and adds an inherent level
of complexity to any kind of current
movement you do and I might even talk
about calcium or all the other ones it's
like you've extended the kinds of
electricity that you can use so because
metal circuits that we build can't do
that they just use electrons they can
never achieve the same level of circuit
complexity that a cell can a biological
system so if recreating in silicon isn't
going to be as we see it in biology you
see plain sci-fi films which one gets it
closest to being right yeah I want to
say like ex machina right but I have to
say transcendence which is like the so
awful but I have to say because in
transcendence they're kind of fun
spoiler alert the point is that Johnny
Depp gets uploaded and he changes right
his consciousness gets ugly yes he dyes
his crosses guys I've made it he changed
not the same Johnny Depp as he was
before
because you if you were to create an
electronic brain which had the
processing power and the memory to hold
all the information that you current
in your brain because it cannot work in
the same way yes if you were to upload
your constants it would change yes you
you would have to necessarily have to be
thinking in a different way the
processes would be different so it is
like transcendence and I am you know
just so sorry
it's sorry ex machina you're a much
better film though you are transcendence
you don't deserve to be in this YouTube
video thank you for watching this video
it's the first one of its kind that I've
made I'm really curious to see what I
could do in the future with this format
in the description I've included a link
to the surprisingly detailed Wikipedia
article about electrical currents in the
brain and also a link to dr. Jennings
science communication project collab lab
thank you again for watching do get the
video alike and consider sharing it if
you enjoyed it